[Music]
[Music]
this episode is brought to you by linked
in marketing solutions the go-to tool
for b2b marketers and advertisers who
want to drive brand awareness generate
leads or build long-term relationships
that result in real business impact
could be all of the above I've had Reid
Hoffman co-founder of LinkedIn on this
podcast a number of times often called
the Oracle of Silicon Valley for many
different reasons and he among other
people and friends of mine have made me
more and more interested in LinkedIn as
a platform as an ecosystem in the last
few years and it's it's very nuanced
it's very subtle but can be used in some
very powerful ways with a community of
more than five hundred and seventy five
million professionals LinkedIn is
gigantic but it can be hyper specific
you have access to a very diverse group
of people all searching for things they
need to grow professionally that is
explicitly the purpose of LinkedIn and
four out of five users on LinkedIn are
decision makers at their companies so
you can build relationships that really
matter that can drive your business
objectives forward that can also have a
high LTV lifetime value LinkedIn has the
marketing tools to help you target your
customers with precision right down to
among other things their job title
company name industry etc this is
important because better targeting
equals a message that your customers
actually care about and it also means
your advertising is more effective and
cost effective so why spray-and-pray
with your marketing dollars when you can
be surgical it just makes sense to
redeem a free $100 LinkedIn ad credit
and launch your first campaign go to
linkedin.com a forward slash TFS that
stands for Tim Ferriss show so that is
linkedin.com forward slash TFS check it
out
that's where you can go to get your free
$100 ad
LinkedIn comport / TFS terms and
conditions apply this episode of the Tim
Ferriss shows brought to you by athletic
greens I get us all the time if I could
only take one supplement what would it
be
the answer is inevitably athletic greens
I view it as and a lot of you now view
it as all-in-one nutritional insurance I
recommended it way back in 2010 in the
4-hour body and I did not get paid to do
so I've been using it since before that
and I use it in a lot of different ways
I travel with it to avoid getting sick
or to help mitigate the likelihood of
getting sick I take it in the morning to
ensure optimal performance and overall
it covers my bases if I can't get what I
need from whole food meals throughout
the rest of the day and if you want to
give athletic greens a try they're
offering a free 20 count travel pack for
first-time users I nearly always travel
with at least three or four of these one
dose bags in other words if you buy
athletic greens as a first-time buyer
you now get for a limited time and extra
$79 in free product so check out the
details at athletic greens dot-com
forward slash Tim again that's athletic
greens dot-com forward slash Tim for
your free travel pack with any purchase
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is Tim Ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the Tim Ferriss show
this is Tim Ferriss and each episode it
is my job to in this case sit outside
and record this introduction it's a bit
of audio Verity and undisclosed location
for recording future episodes but is my
job in each of these episodes to
deconstruct a world-class performer to
try to tease out the lessons habits etc
that you can apply and my guest for this
episode is Ken Block he is a co-founder
of DC Shoes and a professional rally
driver with the hoonigan that's h0n i GA
n hooting in racing division his rally
career began in 2005 and he won Rookie
of the Year that season in the Rally
America championship Ken has accumulated
5 X Games medals and achieved global
fame through his wildly successful viral
series of Gymkhana videos that spelled g
ym k h a n a these videos are
completely bonkers Gymkhana videos
including all associated edits have
racked up more than 500 million views
landing the franchise and Ad Age's
top-ten viral video charts in Jan of
2010 block formed the monster World
Rally Team later renamed to Hoonigan
racing division and signed with Ford to
pursue his dreams of racing in the World
Rally Championship since WRC and in
doing so became one of only four
Americans to ever score points in the
WRC his latest project is the Gymkhana
files which is a series available on
Amazon Prime video and here's the
description quote the Gymkhana files
takes viewers deep behind the scenes of
one of the world's wildest most
successful viral video franchises of all
time with over 500 million online views
and Counting following globally
recognized race car driver and viral
star ken Block and his team of hoonigan
x' as they attempt to make the greatest
automotive video of all time while
racing in the world rallycross
championship back to me so specifically
it takes you guys and me I've watched
the series behind the scenes of filming
Gymkhana ten subtitle the ultimate tire
sling tour a video that as of this
writing it just went up and has more
than 20 million views it's all complete
insanity you have to check it out in any
case you can find more about Ken and
what he's up to
at Hoonigan racing calm on instagram @ k
block 43 twitter k block 43 and facebook
can block racing so without further ado
please enjoy this wide-ranging
conversation with ken block
ken welcome to the show well thanks for
having me I really appreciate it where
are we sitting right now we are sitting
in the Hoonigan racing headquarters in
Park City Utah and we are inside of a
shipping container yes very expensive
shipping but yeah I have about 40
shipping containers that are cut up that
make up my offices and shop here in Park
City and you were explaining this to me
a bit earlier before we started
recording but what is the practicality
of having these shipping containers that
are bolted to the floor well in my
earlier life I was one of the founders
of DC Shoes and we grew from a very
small brand to a very big brand and over
that course of growing we moved probably
five different offices and their form
building all new drywall walls all over
the place and all that and it cost a lot
of money so when I built the race team
offices here I decided I wanted to build
something that you know we kind of have
a recycling message with using you know
things like use skateboards as tile and
you know you shipping containers for
offices that sort of thing but also if I
have to move you can actually pick up
these entire offices and easily move
them somewhere else on a shipping charts
so if you need to upsize or downsize or
anything in between size you have
everything here that you can pack up yep
absolutely and it actually ended up
making a very cool-looking office - we
had a lot of fun
being creative with this office and
doing something unique and different but
also to me is something that kind of on
the leading edge of what I hope people
do in the future with you know empty
warehouse spaces like this in building
offices it's a lot a lot of drywall gets
wasted out there as people change
buildings and change businesses it's a
beautiful space and I'll put up and
certainly there's no shortage of footage
of this space online but I'll put up a
bunch in the show notes as well you've
had a number of different careers and
makes me think of Bruce Wayne in some
respects because you've had you've lived
many lives in one
if this is not gonna be chronological
but first hoonigan where does that name
come from well the word hoon is
basically similar to our laws here in
America of reckless driving so if
someone were to say oh you were hooning
in Australia that would mean you were
out doing something reckless with a car
but what's that term kind of made it
over here to America became like a term
of endearment like oh you're out having
fun with the car great whereas if you
were reckless driving here be like oh
you're gonna get a ticket so you know a
couple you know journalists here in
America started calling me king of the
hoons because I was a race car driver
that was out having fun with my cars
also and around that time is when I
started making the Gymkhana videos so
that was really kind of the epitome of
technical driving but having fun with
the car because it was a race car that I
wasn't racing which is just something
unique and a bit different in the world
of Motorsports
so you know that that word hoon then
became something that we started using
more and more and then we started to
develop the brand of hoonigan the idea
of it and I and I came up with the the
the the term hoonigan and it just kind
of stuck for us and ended up you know
being great for the brand and and now
we've continued to grow and grow I think
we're in our seventh or eighth year with
the brand and you've you have a track
record as a very successful entrepreneur
which was certainly going to dig into
you also are very adept with media and
marketing and branding and you mentioned
Jim Connor for those people who have not
seen it we're gonna talk about that in
just a minute but the the video series
Gymkhana kha na has around or maybe more
than what half a billion views now
collectively yeah the the main videos
themselves have almost half a half a
billion and there's a bunch ancillary
videos around that also and we kind of
keep tabs on all of them and then we
just totaled up the other day it's over
600 million views on all that stuff
altogether so quite insane not
not something I really ever expected to
happen but it's been very cool to kind
of be a part of this sort of visual
digital you know revolution that is how
the Internet has kind of you know
evolved over time and then you have your
competitive career right and then you
have your competitive career and for
some people listening they may think
well much like other sports or even as
we were discussing before we started
recording say motocross you must have
started when you were about four or five
or six years old I started what the
rally car dancing now unfortunately I
think when I was 37 very very old and
the world of Motorsports so I grew up in
Long Beach California skateboarding
right even BMX bikes as a kid and then
moved down to North San Diego my parents
decided they wanted to own an avocado
grove so moved me down to the the
countryside of North San Diego and
continued skateboarding but then started
riding dirt bikes so I'd you know raced
amateur derp bikes when I was you know
my teenage years but didn't actually
start racing cars till I was 37 although
I'd been a fan of rallies since I was
very young I was never a fan of like
American motor sports for some reason
like my brother a drag raced and like
all that I knew all that stuff existed
but as a kid I was most interested in in
in Formula One but really rally like
cars that slid and jumped and raced in
the snow and in through Africa and and
it's just something I related to much
more than a car that just went straight
or went in a circle and I you know don't
no disrespect to those sports it just
wasn't interesting to me and I think
that's also why I loved you know dirt
bikes so much as a teenager was the
creativity of it of jumping of sliding
of you know racing around a track that I
had all these obstacles and really rally
racing was that but with a car and so I
just genuinely loved it for from since I
was quite young but I never had an
opportunity to do anything with it or
even
knew it existed in the States to allow
us around 36 37 now was that was your
first exposure in terms of training at
team O'Neil
or was it somewhere else uh yeah my
first driving rally car driving lesson
was at team O'Neil in New Hampshire and
all kind of roots back to travis
pastrana so at the time I was the chief
brand officer of DC Shoes and travis
pastrana was one of our moto athletes
and travis in 2004 did a couple rallies
and that just woke me up to the fact
that rally even existed in the states
and that I could potentially go do it
and so Travis's agent Steve a Stephon
was a good friend of mine and I called
Steve and I said hey I want to go do
that what Travis is doing how do I do
that so Steve connected me with the team
the team said yeah I come out we'll take
you to a great rally school which ended
up being team O'Neil put me through a
four day course and I was hooked
like I couldn't have enjoyed myself more
and like I felt like I had a little bit
of natural talent for it I could throw
this thing around exactly how I want to
know is pretty quick but no clues to
where that would go I just was like hey
I really like this farm I need to do
this more so I I knew for the first time
about your time in New Hampshire with
team O'Neil because I spent a week there
for a TV show short-lived but still
entertaining all the Tim Ferriss
experiment I went there to train and
compete against a friend of mine and
much like your wall on the other side of
where we're sitting with all of the
damaged and destroyed pieces of various
vehicles there is there was there some
shrapnel from some of your cars up there
in New Hampshire and I found it to be
such I do not have I don't think any
preternatural super skill related to
rally but training with pendulum turns
and you know finish flicks and all that
it's just so endlessly and interesting
and it's genuinely fun it's a fun way to
drive it so much really is
and the science there's so much science
behind it you have people who've done it
from a very very young age I mean
there's certainly a number of countries
that seem to produce a lot of Champions
how at 36 37 did you think about
tackling this seriously uh well you know
at the beginning it was just a hobby you
know the first year I went out and
funded my own racing you know I was just
you know as amateur as an amateur gets
you know first year out you know just
learning the ropes I had a good team
behind me at a great co-driver Alex that
helped a lot but in the beginning it was
just like okay let me figure this out
let me throw everything into it if I'm
really into this and I really did try
and learn as much as I possibly could
and and luckily for me I was already in
very good shape at 37 years old because
I loved riding dirt bikes and with DC I
you know we sponsored guys like Ricky
Carmichael and Jeff Emig Ryan Hughes
Jeremy McGrath like some of the best
guys in the world so I got to go ride
with them so I wanted to be in shape to
go do that stuff you know and being
around guys like that and Danny Way and
Travis Rice and you know Andy Irons
these guys that you know we're the top
of the field in all their their areas
like I got to see how champions trained
I see how they ate I saw you know what
it took to be a champion so I knew how
to train and how to mentally get myself
there and do those things so I was able
to take all that and apply it to myself
to develop my own talent to go do
something that I I love to do and so
2005 was the first year I raced in it
and then I was able to get like fourth
overall in the national championship and
actually beat Travis that year so from
there I was like holy [ __ ] this is fun
and I've got some natural town for and
I'm just gonna put you know as much
effort as I can into doing it and try
and see where it goes you know I had no
idea where it would go but it it ended
up going a lot further than I ever
expected and it's been
a completely wild ride but I really give
a lot of credit back to not only the
experiences that I had with DC of trying
to be successful and figuring out what
it takes to be successful but also
understanding the mental and physical
sides of you know studying and watching
these friends of mine that were
champions and what it what it took for
them to do what they needed to do and
we're gonna we're gonna visit DC very
shortly but since we're on topic does
anything come to mind that
differentiates some of the guys you just
mentioned I mean there's a big names
very competitively successful what did
you see that made them different or what
any behaviors and he beliefs any
practices was there anything in
particular that comes to mind or
anything that comes to mind well I the
funny thing about all those guys is they
all have different stories you know like
there is no magic formula there is no
perfect human that then has the perfect
formula everyone's different
you know what worked for Ricky
Carmichael would not work for Andy Irons
you know like that sort of thing but
what you do see with a lot of those guys
you know that you see with any top
athlete is the drive and determination
you know there's there's guys out there
that that aren't the most talented but
they're willing to outwork everyone you
know and that's kind of where I was I
was an older guy you know 37 38 I'm
competing against 20-year olds you know
and I'm like well I'm just gonna be
smarter you know I'm gonna Train smarter
I'm gonna prepare smarter I'm gonna do
everything everyone find every trick in
the book that I can to maximize the
opportunity and and I think that's
that's really a lot of what it takes in
the end with a lot of athletes there is
a lot of outliers out there the Ricky
Carmichael's the world that just he's
the greatest of all time kind of for
certain reasons that no one else can
match you know but other than that
there's a lot of people out there that
it's it's a matter of mastering the game
always being a student of the game and
finding every little moment where you
can find some sort of advantage in that
that means you have to live it if to
day in day out you cannot be a champion
of a sport generally without you know
that study without the living breathing
existing in that form of sport day-in
day-out and so I think that's the main
thing that that I've seen as a constant
is that dedication to the craft what's
what were some of the tricks were
approaches that you found worked for you
and I'm just thinking moments before we
started this you had your breakfast
slash lunch which was a cup of coffee
with some protein in it some plant
protein plus MCT oil and you commented
that it makes it a lot easier to Train
if you've say consume something like
that rather than having a very heavy
meal so that just jumped to mine is not
necessarily an example from a long time
ago but but a habit that might aid in
training for any number of things right
so are there any other things that you
decided as a 37 year old you're like
okay the 20 year olds are doing a B and
C if I do that I'm not going to be able
to match what they're doing or any other
kind of tricks of the trade that you
ended up adopting for yourself well I
think that with any sport it's about
being smart about what makes you
successful in it you know and you know
for example like I race cars I don't
have to be a shredded strong individual
to do that I power steering a foot pedal
you know so it's more about reaction
time it's more about quickness it's
about you know mental quickness it's
about what it takes to have these
moments where hey at 3:00 in the
afternoon tomorrow I need to be at the
highest cognitive recognition level that
I can possibly be you know so what's it
take to get me there is it supplements
is it training is it a particular
exercise that I do before I get in the
car so a lot of it to me is experiment
you know it's it's working with the
right people that help you it's
different training exercises and a lot
of it is just you know
trial and error and figuring out what
works and what doesn't work and when
something you know when a mistake does
happen trying to figure out what caused
that mistake and then how do I correct
it and and make myself better for the
next time what were some of the things
you've found to work I know you've been
a long term it seems like trainee with
kickboxing and have worked with some
fantastic athletes do you have a
particular you mentioned exercise before
getting into the car do you have
particular exercise or any exercise do
you do well you know what I grew up in
North San Diego do you know Paul jack is
I do yes yes so Paul check I've worked
with many Paul check trainers have
worked with Paul check himself and so I
grew sort of up in my training world
around people that you know really
worked with you know those sort of ball
exercises and balanced exercises all
that sort of stuff to really mimic more
real-world balance needs as opposed to
just grabbing a barbell and doing curls
you know so that sort of all that
training to me helped a lot but then
upping the level that I worked with a
couple trainers that you know would help
me with
mental skills along with those physical
skills so with rally you're having to
hear notes oh so you drive down a road
let's say ten miles long twisty you know
whiny going through forests you're going
90 miles an hour sideways next to trees
and while you're doing that you're
hearing notes that's that's telling you
what's coming up next and it's in their
triggers they're not like hey by the way
there's a left coming up it's really
dangerous no it's left five key pin you
know caution and those have to be
triggers in your mind do you
automatically react upon and drive as
quickly through every situation as
possible so we would actually do that
stuff in the gym where I would actually
be training doing a particular exercise
and my trainer would have me looking or
listening the things and then having to
react to that with certain triggers that
I would then react with and it was all
sort of brain type exercises on top of
that even bouncing balls off a wall
having to react with my eyes closed open
them and react and catch a ball it was
all about being able to see peripherally
see directly in front of me see short
distance see long distance all that sort
of thing so it was a lot more really
these little little things that are
harder to Train with your brain that
would potentially make you quicker
because you know rally we're battling
for seconds over each stage with
rallycross you're battling for tenths of
a second each lap and if you can do that
quicker than your competition because of
what how you've trained and that's one
way to be faster mm-hmm
so you're a student of success and maybe
we could rewind the clock a little bit
and get back to DC now I was doing as I
always do homework for this conversation
and it seems like DC was certainly not
your first business and maybe you could
tell us a bit about how you got into
entrepreneurship because I'm reading I
have eight ball clothing blunt magazine
drawers clothing
how did entrepreneurship enter your life
how did you end up in business well the
funny thing about that is I I didn't I
didn't necessarily intend to be an
entrepreneur in the beginning but it
just kind of seemed like the only Avenue
not the only Avenue it seemed like the
the avenue that I was left with with the
things that I love to do and my
interests so the the funny thing is I
start off in high school studying
architecture I want to be an architect
and I did all sorts of draft drafting
through high school and then when I got
out of high school I went straight to a
computer-aided drafting school and did
that for a year and then I got into the
business and I hated it
hey I loved it as an art and I loved it
as a study but actually the the business
of it I just didn't like well I what
didn't you like about it I I guess
because it is but the only people that
get to do the art of architectures are
the people at the top right and it takes
either a ton of money or you know 30 to
40 years
of climbing to the top and I just saw
that once I realized being in the
business what it took and I just said
yeah that isn't for me so you know it
being a skateboarder and a snowboarder
you know I wanted to do that stuff more
so I actually quit working for this
architecture firm and ended up moving to
Breckenridge Colorado for two years of
being a snowboard bomb and I was
actually friends with a bunch of you
know Pro snowboarders and I looked up to
those guys I wanted to be them but in
the end I just knew I didn't have the
talent I just I didn't have the skill
set that they had and I saw that so I
moved back to California
and went back to college and started
studying screen printing graphic design
graphic layout all that sort of stuff
and I just really enjoyed it and I
thought I could you know because of my
interest in skateboarding snowboarding I
started designing some shop t-shirts for
one of the shops that I was friends with
out in Colorado and you know I thought
oh this would be great if I could
actually be a part of this industry I
love and in the meantime at the same
schools Palomar College in Vista
California
I met Damon way who's the older brother
of the legendary skateboarder Danny Way
and Damon and I hit it off and we both
had interests in trying to be in the
industry of skateboarding and
snowboarding and we had this real mutual
interest in that and I was I was more of
the graphics business type guy and he
was more of the clothing designer type
guy and so we just kind of merged our
talents and started working together and
started very small with 8-ball and
drawers and you know eventually I did a
magazine called blunt as part of this
whole company and we sold a company
called type-a snowboards which were some
friends of ours we own part of that and
eventually we started DC so we were kind
of lucky with DC that we got all this
experience of a couple years floundering
around with these other clothing
companies and Maggie
but we learned a lot so that by the time
we got to making DC which is tooth 94-95
that we were able to make this startup
worked very well very quickly so we
already had the infrastructure of
buildings and artists and salespeople
and warehouse and all that so that when
DC got plugged into that it it took off
but we were able to manage it and make
it work if we had to had all that other
stuff and experience and all that we we
wouldn't have had all that now one thing
I did forget to mention in all that
though as you know business is not easy
to start you know and and I come from a
family my dad had his own business and
he was fairly successful with it and my
parents by the time that I was a
teenager had a decent amount of money I
wouldn't say they were overly rich but
you know they were you know they had
enough money to buy 16 acres of avocados
in a house you know in Valley Center and
so as I was growing up you know I I
wanted certain things you know like
there were kids in my school that drove
BMWs I'm like I want that my dad just
laughs he's like no way am i buying you
that you know like you are going to earn
everything that you get and so I grew up
with that mentality that whatever I did
my parents were not going to give me
anything they were going to they were
going to help me but they were gonna
make me work for it and so that's
something that I really genuinely
appreciate and something I'm gonna pass
on to my own kids that like life isn't
easy you've got to figure certain things
out and you've got to make it work and
it takes hard work to be successful and
I've seen a lot of people have stuff
given to them and they've floundered
with it and I think that experience
really is the best lesson yeah and so
when I when I was starting our business
you know I went to my parents and said
hey I need some money and my my mom said
well I'm not sure that my dad will do
that but let's try she said write a
business plan you know if you want 10
grand proved to us what you're gonna do
with that 10 grand and how you're gonna
pay us back I said okay so I bought
books and figured out I'm gonna make a
business plan wrote that business plan
and I got 10 grand out of my parents to
help start the business that was DC that
was actually for a ball and drawers and
Damon came in with some money and we
were equal partners in the beginning but
really it was from my parents and my
parents you know however you'd like to
say ethics law you know business family
ethics that basically set me in motion
of how to learn business how to start a
business how to pay back alone all that
stuff because you know I was at 19 20
year old kid that was just trying to
better himself and they helped me set
the path to do what I did and that's
something that I that I genuinely
appreciate and anytime anybody asked me
from from like how do I start this
business or how do I get sponsored the
easiest lesson is if you don't know
business and you don't know what
marketing budgets are and you don't know
advertising or sales like you've got to
understand that stuff and understand the
business plan to go anywhere you know
and there's so much basics of life that
if you understand you know how products
get made and how Putin how companies
profit and what it takes to spend
advertising dollars there's so much in
life that you will understand just by
knowing those basics and you have you
have such a keen eye you studied
architecture I'd I've watched a lot of
what you've done over the years and I
just want to underscore maybe using
different words the value of someone who
has artistic ability in learning the
business side is not sullying your hands
with some crass aspect of the world
necessarily but enabling yourself to
further the art and what you want to do
in the world right and it's a real
liability not to have that and what's
struck me also is that you have these
seemingly disparate lives that you've
led and success in these different
realms but they've also built on one
another in the sense that you sponsored
athletes and now you are a sponsored
athlete and you know how to do you know
which athletes you sponsor did a great
job versus a mediocre job versus did a
do not pass job
and so you're able to fulfill that role
really really effectively for the
companies you work with right like the
Fords and the monsters whoever might be
and you have an operational awareness
that enables you to then pursue the
craft that you want to pursue let me ask
you about we're gonna talk about good
decisions and resources that helped you
and so on and so forth but do any misty
well before you go on though let's let's
talk about that real quick yeah um that
was one of the things that when I trance
like the transition for me from going
from chief brand officer at DC to
racecar driver it was actually real it
was there was a bit difficult for me at
first and mainly because as chief brand
officer DC I actually liked to be in the
background like I I Damon and I didn't
really like us getting press for DC we
liked the athletes to be the the people
that stood out front and represented the
brand so as I became a racecar drivers
like of crap now I kind of put my face
out there and I've got to be the voice
and and I have to you know show a
different attitude and a different not
necessarily different but I had to be
worried about what I said and how I said
it and how I presented myself which I
just didn't have to worry about before
that you know but so that transition was
a bit tough but once I got into it I
basically said okay I know it bothered
me or I saw the the good and bad of all
these athletes that I worked with for
you know 15 years before this so how can
I take all those experiences what I
liked and disliked about what all these
different people did and make myself the
best of what I can make myself and I'll
tell you a really stupid example like
you know we had guys that we would send
out to a shop to do an autograph signing
and there'd be you know thousand kids
lined up waiting for this these guys to
sign autographs and and some of them
said of being engaged with these fans
they'd be you know looking at their
phone or turning around smoking a
cigarette you know
kids and stuff like that and it just
they they didn't have the right
understanding of what they were there to
do you know and and to me that's a real
simple example that when I go to you
know an autograph signing you know we
tried to make the best poster we I tried
to be as engaged as possible always
trying to make the fan as happy as
possible they're there you know for me
and I'm there representing all these
different brands and maybe you know the
shop that I'm there for those sort of
things so it's it's understanding them
the whole situation because of where I
came from before which has then made me
such a great ambassador for all these
brands and and hopefully a very good and
engaged athlete for these fans that
follow me so it's been a very fun
process to go from that guy behind the
scenes that it kind of understands it
all because I wrote the contracts I made
the ads I directed the social media you
know we made commercials I made skate
videos you know as to now being the guy
on the other side and delivering what
the sponsors needed so and there were
certain guys that like actually pissed
me off over the years that I saw so much
potential for it and just watch him fail
because they didn't understand that I
said you know I'm gonna prove whether
these guys ever see this or not I'm
gonna prove what is potential if you
just understand the process you know and
that's actually been very fun for me
over the years you know maximizing the
potential of social media you know
really maximizing the potential of
YouTube and delivering what the fans
want because at the end of the day this
is all a business you know like I love
to race cars at the end of the day but
without the sponsors without the series
that are out there without all the fans
there's a whole culture here that all
interacts and goes together but you know
if you don't do it right you you can't
be as successful as but the potential is
there to be and did you even when we
were walking around this building
earlier you were mentioning learning
from every success learning from every
failure
you had your informal business school so
to speak in the in the form of starting
these businesses before DC what were
some of the mistakes that you made in
some of those earlier ventures or you're
like okay now that we're doing DC weird
we are not going to do these following
things we're not going to make these
following mistakes and it just brings to
mind like one for me four instances in
one of the first companies I I started
became really interested in radio
advertising but I knew nothing about it
and so I bought remnant space I thought
I was so smart because there is a huge
discount on space for drive time I was
like oh my god drive time perfect I
found a needle in a haystack and then
all of my ads were run like 4:45 a.m.
because it was defined in the contract
drive times like 4:30 to 9:30 and so I
just lost it alright so that's all I
learned a lot of lessons in that one but
do any particular mistakes or failures
come to mind that it kind of informed
what you did with DC in any way well I
think that all marketing and advertising
it you know a lot of people don't
realize they're like oh we have a
hundred grand to spend sweet you know
well you need to turn that hundred grand
into say a million dollars worth of
business so it's about targeting and
having the right message to reach the
consumer that's actually going to buy
the product and that can be very
difficult and there can be very many
opinions with that and even in a company
you can have ten different opinions on
that even have some personal agendas
thrown in you know and so it it can be
very difficult and you know a lot of it
is a learning lesson and you got to look
at everything else that's out there and
what your competition is doing and and
try and do it better but you know it's a
it's a difficult process and it's one
that you really have to work at and
think through and I mean I've had so
much random stuff like your example
right there I had one of our athletes it
was like I want a boss I'm gonna build a
bus it's gonna be 300 grand I need 300
grand out of you and it will put a big
logo on it everybody on the freeway it's
gonna see it and I'm like I don't care
about everybody on the freeway like
those are my can
Zoomers like if we're going to spend 300
grand we need to spend that targeted
specifically on who we think is gonna
buy our product you know for a DC who
was that like who is your archetype of
your your customer like who was your
customer in the early days
uh well DC I mean it would we were
mainly selling the skate shops in the
beginning so you know you're talking you
know teenage kids mostly boys that were
going in and buying the shoes to
skateboard in so you know back in those
days mid 90s you know we had all the
skateboard magazines because that's when
magazines were still existed and we're
big you know so we had at least one to
two ads a month that we were making the
drop in all those magazines and then you
add various video projects and there was
like four one one magazine the video
magazine and and then on top of that you
you sponsored we have sponsor sponsored
maybe ten to twelve skateboarders that
were you know the top guys in the
industry that fit our brand and so you
know you have all sorts of different
genres of you know types of
skateboarders out there same as like you
know basketball there's there's you know
guys that like high-top shoes guys are
like low top shoes there's guys you know
so you have different athletes that
represent different things like that
so we you know spent all our marketing
dollars to attract those teenage kids to
come into the skate shops and and buy it
and over time as the brand grew and we
did more and more sales you know that we
expanded to more mall stores you know
and so that kid isn't affected as much
by you know the pro skateboarder and the
the skateboard magazine so then we
started working with artists like Mike
Shinoda from Lincoln Park and we had you
know a Mike custom signature shoe and
and did stuff like that and eventually
we worked with artists you know like
cause people like that so you know as we
branched out into more of youth culture
as opposed to only skateboarding we
found our unique marketing angles to do
that and do
fun and innovative ways and grew the
brand's I think at its peak it you know
of 2007-2008 or something was around 550
million so it it really grew to be quite
a big brand and was actually on target
there was a plan at one time with a guy
that was running our company nicked to
be a billion-dollar brand unfortunately
he never made it there because of some
problems the Quicksilver was having who
would bought us in 2004 but it was
incredible to take a brand from nothing
you know to over 500 million in sales a
year it's used accomplishment what is DC
stand for DC actually stands for drawers
clothing so almost every word or
variation of the word in the English
language is trademarked in some way you
know or another and so as we are trying
to work on names for the brand you know
we had all sorts of names that we
submitted and everything was taken you
know DC was actually I had made DC logos
for drawers you know because drawers
clothing it's just an abbreviation you
know something you could make a simple
logo and put on a sleeve and so I knew
that I could make logos and art for that
so we submitted that and it came back
that yeah that was possible to do so the
crazy thing about trademarks though is
even when you trademark something for
one category doesn't mean that it's good
for another category right so eventually
we made snowboards but the logo that we
have looks kind of like Chanel and
Chanel actually has that trademark for
snowboards
so that's why you never see our logo
done the way it is on shoes on a
snowboard really random bit of side
legal information there but yeah that's
the sort of thing you deal with with the
company oh for sure and just a side note
for people excite into this a lot with
people who are starting businesses
intellectual property is really really
nuanced and having a trademark or having
a patent does not protect you it just
gives you the right to sue someone who
infringe is right this is just really
important like you oh yeah like the
actual expense spent over years
protecting our trademark around the
world as millions and millions of
dollars yeah you know and it's just it's
a fact of business and it's an ugly
world it's not any fun you know and I've
been various parts of the world and
shown up and found like bootleg versions
of our shoes and not even like good big
versions they came straight from our
factories to or they're like oh we have
too many of these Souls and too many of
these uppers we'll just put them
together and sell them out the back door
you know and it's really unfortunate but
that that is the world we live in
unfortunately part of the ride you
mentioned a book when we were walking
around that that that beautifully
colored table tennis golf platform over
there I when did that so Dale Carnegie
just just to kick off a conversation and
maybe resources and other things that
have helped you in your entrepreneurial
journey so what was the book and when
did it when did it when did it appear
well the simple background of that is I
you know I was a young 20-something and
all of a sudden I have a business and
I've got to manage it and I have no
management experience you know like I
didn't I didn't go to you know work in
some other company and rise up through
management and learn management skills I
went straight from junior college to
having my own business you know and and
our our business opportunity was growing
every year it was successful every year
and it was successful because you know
my business partner Damon and I worked
very hard but we were we were working on
our talents and after a while those
talents were starting to run out we were
successful but for us to continue to
grow we needed smarter people than us
around us and that meant that we need to
hire them we needed to manage them and
you know no matter what in every company
you you have you know ups and downs of
dealing with people and success based on
the people you surround yourself with
and so I needed to grow as a person in
that position and I knew that you know
management was really you know
the keys so the first actual book that I
picked up to learn you know
communication skills and management
skills was how to win friends and
influence people by Dale Carnegie and I
don't know how old about it I would I
would say it's at least 40 probably 50
or 60 years old I think it's older than
that it's a guy like yes yeah it's a
it's a it's a fantastic book parts of it
are a little dated and kind of make you
chuckle or cringe depending but great
book yeah but but I think that book you
know I think that there's a there's a
lot of good lessons in it and I like the
attitude even the title like how to win
friends and influence people and that
that actually fits very well with like
how I like to manage how I like to work
with people and a lot of it is about
working as a collective and getting
people on a team to accomplish something
as opposed to just being a director and
barking orders so I've always in jet
enjoyed the collaborative effort of
working in a company that hey we're
trying to get this done we're trying to
you know finish this campaign whatever
it is and everybody knows and
understands the goals and we've set a
bar and we've set this bar high how do
we all get there
and that book was really one of the
first books that really kind of helped
me achieve my management style and
what's helped me really be successful
there's there's plenty of other books
you know like the habits of millionaires
all that sort of stuff those books do
but I think that book really was part of
kind of what shaped me as a business
person and a director if we look at the
eat let's just say the apparel business
I've spent a good amount of time around
say Daymond John right at FUBU which
stands for for us by us by the way for
people who don't know that and the or
you know Mark Ecko
in the early days and it's a tough or it
can be a really tough business right
where people are relatively
undifferentiated and and it's there in
some cases depending on the scale
obviously ah it's it's an appealing
business for a lot of people to go into
so what were some of the key decision
or approaches you took that were
different enough that led to this
year-on-year growth like was it
innovation on how you approach the
stores was it something very unusual
about your marketing obviously you did a
lot with product innovation also but
like what what were the ingredients
right because there are a lot of players
potentially a lot of players in that
world well I did that's tough question
now yeah but you know when I look back
on at one thing that that always the
Dayman and I always thought about was
really like the easiest thing is saying
set the bar very high and when you say
that you know like okay well how does
that apply like does that mean you make
a really nice t-shirt well no it you
know that's part of it but you've a lot
of it is has to do with like okay if
we're gonna go do marketing how do we do
it unique and different how do we be
creative you know the the thing about
the world today is it's easy to make a
t-shirt but how do you get someone to
buy it why is supreme you know um you
know more desirable than say you know
something else you know just for a
random example even throwing you know
Reebok or something else like that yeah
the kids definitely gonna take the
supreme shirt or the Reebok sure you
know so but that because that is because
of a brand essence you've sold someone a
story you've sold someone an image and
to do that and to do it at a very high
level is very difficult you know it
takes years of development and and and
really having that bar set so high and
kind of judging everything against that
bar so that you end up with you know
marketing projects that are huge and
different and really capture people's
attention or you have products that lead
in the industry or that you have you
know athletes that really stand out and
stand right along with you with their
huge accomplishments and represent your
brand with them at the same time so it's
kind of all those things in one that
they create this brand essence for you
know everyone from you know big
companies like Nike and Apple down to
you know small brands even like us with
hoonigan so if you can capture the
interest of the consumer you know with
the right story that touches the right
nerves in each of these markets then you
can really set yourself apart and then
drive that consumer to buy the product
because at the end of the day a t-shirt
pretty easy to make yeah
even nowadays a pair of shoes pretty
easy to make lots of competitors out
there so how do you grab the attention
of that consumer and say buy ours
instead of theirs you know can you think
of a particular campaign or a particular
athlete that was just the Willy Wonka
golden ticket where you guys really kind
of aced the whole or one that completely
face-planted we're like okay this is the
reason why this didn't work well back in
the day when we started drawers like we
were you know a couple of industry guys
me and Damon that you know we we didn't
have the experience that a lot of the
other companies that we were competing
against had and but we just had a vision
we had an idea of what we wanted to do
and and we came up with some very
innovative marketing concepts not
hopefully only four drawers but into DC
but the the first thing that really
started us off and drawers was just
coming up with really fun and unique
like kind of twisted ideas and you know
Rob Dyrdek who's now a fairly big MTV
star he was one of our skateboarders
back then and one of our first ads that
really stood out and the magazine's was
literally just I'd pour blue paint over
his head and he was smoking a cigarette
we just had these really obscure photos
of just his head was blue paint being
poured over it we were selling clothing
there was no clothing in the ad you know
but this is the early 90s and we were
just trying to be a bit outlandish and
different than what everybody else was
doing in the magazine world at that time
in the skateboard world I should say and
it was much more of sort of a fuck-you
fashion style attitude and it just
really worked you know and
we kind of played on that idea of you
know just being rebellious through the
years and it's fun because skateboarders
are generally like that so it was fun
really playing into that over the years
DC as we are growing it got a bit more
professional the style of DC was kind of
a bit more of like a much more slicker
style skateboard shoe more performance
so we kind of played into that over the
years and had some funny tag lines and
made kind of creative but slick ads but
in the end like one of the biggest
things that we ever did was build a
giant ramp like what's called the mega
ramp for Danny way to do basically giant
skateboarding tricks that had never been
done it's sort of the scale and that was
around 2003 2004 and that had really
made us and him stand out in a way that
it really that was we were seeing
skateboarding go to like a whole new
level to the point where X Games adopted
that ramp and put it in the X Games and
I think it's the biggest mega ramp style
is still in the X Games today but all
initiated from Danny thinking in an
innovative and different way and in us
funding it and creating a video part all
around this and that was just the type
of stuff that we did the set DC you know
far apart from all of our competition
was there anything with pricing or
distribution you're mentioning the
contracts with the athletes that comes
to mind that outside of kind of product
and marketing you guys did differently
haha we're gonna come back to video for
sure that seems to be very native medium
yeah on the business side you know like
I said earlier David and I were smart
about you know realizing we weren't the
smartest guys in the room and to hire
those people you know and then manage
the expectations of what we were trying
to do and grow the business how did you
find those people who how did we find
him some of them were friends
some were friends of friends guy that
ran our business for a while was
actually the father of someone I went to
high school with
and then as we grew bigger and bigger we
used headhunters to go out and you know
steal people from Nike for sales and
stuff like that you know you know that's
just the reality of yet big business is
you know if you're trying to go a
certain place you know like with sales
you need to hire the guys that do that
for someone else you know and and we you
know would hire and find and hire the
right people and we were able to to grow
quite quite well over the years but you
know that that's that that's the tough
part about business I I was a marketing
guy you know I was very good at design I
had some design experience you know from
doing architecture in high school and I
ended up basically designing the first
15 models of our shoes you know with
some of the pro athletes but I did the
drawings I flew to Korea I immersed
myself in the business and said this is
what I have to do to succeed and did it
you know but doesn't mean I'm a good
salesperson doesn't mean every good
accountant and you just got to hire the
right people and be able to manage them
and if they can't perform the management
site you has to fire them and move on
and hire someone better you know and to
me that's a big part of success is
understanding your strengths and
weaknesses and hiring the people to
really help make a business successful
that you can't do everything yourself
you you there's no way at least in my
mind there's no way that you can be a
brand director along with you know an
incredible accountant amazing sales
person but you just have to have the
wherewithal to understand what those
jobs you know what it takes to succeed
in those jobs and then hire the right
people to do it so it's that's one thing
I've really learned probably in a big
way over all this is that you know it
really takes a big community of smart
people to make something successful but
at the top you still need to be able to
set that bar and manage that bar to get
something where you know you intend it
to be did you guys up until the the
acquisition by Quicksilver did you self
fund or did you bring in
financing for the business along the way
uh no we we self-funded we had our names
on very large lines of credit which I
genuinely hated which was all the
reasons why we eventually sold that like
it you know the liability of that if
there was a down year or the economy
crash or something that the business
would have gone away quite quickly
because you know we didn't have you know
we were not cash heavy we were
definitely very debt heavy but that's
what we needed to grow and how we did
grow and and it made for a very
successful company but also that that
can make things volatile and in the long
run and that's why we saw a purchase
with someone like Quicksilver is a very
good sort of route to a to a good end
for us and it worked out really quite
well it's a video I promise to get back
to video let's talk about Gymkhana v
specifically just as someone who is
because that was the first Gymkhana
video I saw I was in I lived in San
Francisco for almost 20 years before
moving and I would imagine I'm way to
describe it for people who haven't seen
it everybody should see it by the way
last time I checked ahead I'm sure it'll
be past a 100 million by the time most
people hear this but 99 million or so
views at least one version of it on
YouTube so quite a few people have seen
this and it is it is really
mind-boggling to watch this video and I
will maybe gonna describe for people but
also yeah I hope in in describing it for
people explain how it seems at least
from the editing that you basically shut
down San Francisco to do this because
you don't see a soul on the streets so
what what is Gymkhana v maybe that's a
way of explaining what Gymkhana is and
everybody should absolutely go check
this and all the other Gymkhana videos
out but almost 100 million views what
what is Gymkhana I love how you just
jumped past for very viral video 5
because all of the tech nerds were my
friends live in San Francisco and they
were just like what in the [ __ ]
is this yeah well the funny thing about
that is Gymkhana 5 is my favorite video
you know we started making these videos
the first one it took us two days to
produce it was a very small team and it
was the first time that we really had a
video because we'd made several like
recap videos of me and Travis racing I'd
done some stuff with Nitro Circus I'd
done a 170 foot jump like I'm a dirtbike
track with my rally car for a program
called stunt junkies that got like 10
million views but Gymkhana the first
Gymkhana video that we did it's called
Gymkhana testing and practice it was the
first real viral video it got like 10
million views in a couple weeks and then
just kept going and it was actually this
was before YouTube was really popular so
it I had a video player on my ken Block
website and it got like 10 million views
there alone and finally I was paying for
the same thing for this you know this
website to host this and it was costing
a lot of money I'm like [ __ ] we got to
put this on YouTube this is just costing
me too much money you know so that's
kind of how long ago this was it was
over ten years ago that you know we
started doing this and it's weird to me
that you think about this today that
YouTube wasn't the video standard that
it is now people were still putting
videos kind of all over the place
because YouTube today is just the
standard like every you know it everyone
puts stuff there from you know the Daily
Show to you know the YouTube you know
community that some of them have
subscribers in the millions you know so
anyway we created this video and it was
really fashioned after skateboarding so
a skateboarding video part a guy will go
out and say you know he'll skateboard
and try and capture certain tricks on
film for a year and he'll go to a
certain handrail and he'll try 30 times
and slam 29 times roll away on the 30th
time and they make sure they get all the
best angles of it
you know and they'll take you know 20 of
these tricks and put them together to
make a video part and it's just the best
of what this person can do and this has
done a lot in skateboarding snowboarding
surfing motocross like they make these
videos that are then sold to you know to
the consumers so basically I kind of
created that same thing but with a car
so I went and did you know a certain
number of tricks and slides and around
different obstacles at a Airport called
El Toro and Irvine and that's what the
first term kind of video was and I
thought it was really cool it wasn't
about trying to do something in one try
it was about trying something ten times
to get the perfect shots to make it look
really good and kind of tell this story
of driving around this Airport and kind
of put it all together kind of as a
course and when we first put it out I
was like I really like this video kind
of showcases what I want to watch what
me and my friends want to watch and when
we put that out well it's turned out
that a lot of other people like to watch
it too and that video really took off
and so my sponsors said hey when you got
to do that again we really like that
exposure and so DC paid for me to do the
second one and the third one and the
fourth one and then the fifth one being
San Francisco now the second third and
fourth one all are sort of very similar
filming concept but we just found
different locations the second one was
on some piers in Long Beach third one
was a really unique old racecourse in
France that has this banked these banked
walls that go up to 51 degrees Gymkhana
four was on the one of the studio Lots
up in Hollywood so you know you've got
jaws and you've got the War of the
Worlds and like all these different sets
that I was driving through that made a
really unique thing but these were all
closed sets right you know like private
airfield and private racetrack and that
sort of thing and for Jim count of three
we'd actually gone to San Francisco it's
not San Francisco Detroit and scouted
Detroit and
we went to go get the permits to film
there the city was like we don't like
certain locations you've picked we're
like well why you know
to us everybody knows Detroit is you
know part of the Rust Belt it's an
industrial city that like you know isn't
so industrial Morin has a lot of urban
decay and we like the urban decay and we
had some new stuff in there too but a
lot of Detroit to us was very cool urban
decay and I wanted to drive in and
through a lot of that and they just
didn't like that they wanted to veto
even on set they could say no we don't
like what you're filming and veto us so
there's no way we could put up all this
money to go film at a location where
they're gonna randomly veto in the
middle of shooting so we never ended up
doing Detroit we just thought ah it's
gonna be too difficult so anyway getting
to Gymkhana five we went and scattered
an area outside of San Francisco that's
like an old military base where they
used to build a lot of bombs and
warships and that sort of thing right on
the water and it was cool but it didn't
have enough creative driving situations
to really make a whole video so we went
looked at it and we're kind of
disappointed and we're driving back into
town to get the airport and the Scout
does with us had just scouted San
Francisco for I think Iron Man 3 so he's
a very high-level scout that does
Hollywood type stuff and he's like hey
you want to go check out these spots in
San Francisco you know and we just kind
of laughed like San Francisco's never
gonna let us do this in their city you
know it wasn't nothing to do against San
Francisco it was more of the idea like
we're hooning with cars we're having fun
with cars I'm doing giant slides and
Donuts with a car there's no way a
city's gonna let us do that but also we
just didn't understand sort of the movie
world as well back then and so the scat
was like no no we do whatever we want we
get a permit we we have that Street to
do whatever we want you know and so he
took us to a couple locations and we
were kind of blown away we're like
really we couldn't use these locations
and so you know he had some good stuff
but we said
we need a jump we need the snap you need
a real twisty Street
we need something down by the water and
so he came back to us like a month later
it was like hey I have all that stuff
you ready to go look again so we went
back to San Francisco and looked at
everything he brought us and we said wow
we have enough here to make an amazing
video we still need a few little things
but you know we have enough here and
then in that process - the city came
back and said hey do you want the bridge
like they offered us absolutely how do
you get the Bay Bridge how do you clear
the baby I would have never even thought
that would be possible but but that's
the thing that's that's interesting
about all this says as we went through
this process you learn oh like a city
like San Francisco where a lot of TV
shows are shot a lot of movies are shot
a lot of commercials are shot like
there's a very good film department
there the the police force are very
adept to understanding what the needs
are for these movies and things and and
they they understand what what you need
to do to do this so the they offered us
the bridge we're like I would have never
thought we're gonna shut down the Bay
Bridge and use the Bay Bridge but
they're like oh yeah we do that Sunday
morning we block them over by like
between Oakland they start over they get
on the bridge over by Oakland then as
they get towards the island
I don't remember eyes rather than yeah I
think it's I start slowing everybody
down yeah and when they have everybody
start to slow down the traffic then
empties out ahead of them and then we
get on at Treasure Island or whatever
that's called yeah and then go out and
do it we need to do where the traffic's
still stopped before the island we have
10 or 15 minutes to do it we need to do
then we move on then the cops just let
the traffic go so really they're only
stopped for 10 or 15 minutes yeah and we
did that I think four times so you know
it messes up some traffic but for a
short amount of time on a Sunday morning
which is you know the least amount of
traffic on that bridge so it's all about
just really smart usage of public
streets
I would have never understood all that
unless we actually done that project now
we've shut down like the busiest road in
Dubai
you know the main strip through Dubai
that had only been shut down once before
for the George W Bush Senior so he was
the only one that they'd ever shut it
down for before that you know so it's
been kind of wild to go on this ride of
like ah they'll never let us do that
like shutting down some of the biggest
cities in the world to do some of this
it's really astonishing I mean I never
would have thought it possible is it an
is it a function of lista the scouting
ace that you had or someone else putting
together a pitch for the city like this
is what we're planning this is why it's
going to bring a lot of tourism or is it
really just the infrastructure set up we
are gonna film this is how much you know
what what is the retail price point for
this what's what's the rate card yeah
shutting down this that the exposure is
a good thing they do look at that like
San Francisco looked at into it okay
yeah that's that's good
you know like these this is a viral
series that could potentially give San
Francisco more exposure but the other
day I just think it's money yeah like
you're paying the Film Commission the
city the government to go to this you
know and the city's getting paid the
police department is getting paid you
know it's a it's a commerce system ya
know and so you know and there's a lot
of there's a lot of jobs around that
that are being produced to everything
from our crew to beat all the guys that
you know there's certain streets that
they don't want marks on so you know
we're having to pay local guys to come
in to clean up marks you know so it it
really is kind of a wild process and no
shortage of marks yeah in that video
yeah you know and if you look back at
that video it
it's like San Francisco to me is one of
the most unique driving cities in the
world
and not only is it have some amazing
driving situations like Russian Hill
some of the twisty streets all the
elevation changes all that but it's also
been immortalized by movies like bullet
for sure you know like bullet wasn't
filmed in Akron Ohio
San Francisco you know like jumping down
those crazy streets and the bridges and
everything and that's what makes it so
legendary you know in its essence as San
Francisco as a unique place for cars you
know so when I when we were got the
permission to do that like oh man it was
it was really quite an honor and very
cool to me that we were going to San
Francisco to make this video you know
and and I'll tell you that like I'm very
lucky I have an incredibly great crew
around me of smart very innovative and
creative guys and that's what helps me
make these things - when you watch that
video there's a ton of things in there
that I do with the car but I can't do
that without the great race team behind
me and the great creative team behind me
- it's a very big collaborative effort
for us - to do these things and and not
only that even my experience in
connections in the industry we have
travis Pastrana in there doing a wheelie
that that's you know part of one of the
elements of the movie and and that's a
part of you know the system and
everything that's built into what we do
with you know my agent is Travis's agent
and Travis is a longtime friend of mine
you know so it's it's it's such a great
mix of friendships creativity and
hard-working people that make this
happen
if you're comfortable talking about it
just because I'm I'd certainly sort of a
burning question in my mind putting
aside the separating out the production
caustic but to put the production cost
on one side meaning all the cameras all
the crew for the actual filming what
does it we don't have to make it
specific to San Francisco but to shut
down areas like that in San Francisco
what is sort of range from cost and
doing something like that do you any
idea the funny answer to that question
is I ignore budgets I get to focus on
the creative stuff you know and that is
the honest truth I
I only deal with budgets when they sit
there seem to be overages and most of
that times caused by me like yes I we
can use the Hollywood sign but it's
gonna cost another day yeah let's really
do that
but luckily for what I've been doing
there there's been a lot of success with
this and and DC you know funded the
first five videos and I didn't have to
deal with any of the budgets that there
is always a marketing director that
figured that into his budget and you
know we did I think five years worth of
those videos with them and then since
then my agent and hoonigan have dealt
with you know working with companies
like Forza and Ford and Toyota to fund
all these projects and you know there's
there's a cost to doing it you know and
the more creative you are and the more
extravagant you are the more the cost is
but likely you know we've had a great
set of sponsors that really understand
and see the value in this and have
really kind of let us go wild and get
these things done this the sky is not
the limit there are some very distinct
budget restrictions but you know that
these have been big budget things
there's there's you know movies that
have sold in Hollywood you have smaller
budgets and what we work with you know
but it's it's very cool to do this
process and the the the creativity that
goes into it all through the process of
production everything it is on some of
the highest level there is that with
people that we work with in Hollywood
and it's really cool to be able to do
that and have directors like Neill
Blomkamp you know email me and be like
dude I want to direct what are your
videos and I'm like I love district ID
yes how can we get you involved you know
but it's it's just been a really fun
wild ride and a really fun extension of
not only my creativity as a marketing
person but also the creativity I'd love
to do with the race car itself and at
the same time you know whenever we were
having um well Vegas meandering around
the kitchen earlier you have somewhere
between 4.5 and 5 million followers on
Instagram and you you were mentioning
how we were discussing the affordability
of the gear that I'm recording this
podcast on right now you're saying that
some of the
some of the the most popular pics and so
on they've put up I have in some cases
just been from an iPhone right or
something like that what in your mind
for people who may not have a high
budget and I've seen footage that seems
to also do well for instance where even
recently in British Columbia where you
were snowboarding and had roman candles
as you're going down through powder what
what advice would you give to people who
are hoping to create videos that get
attention ah that's a tough question um
but I love tough questions well it's
it's a tough question I feel like in in
general like in marketing in society in
whatever because today like we're saying
t-shirts yeah it's easy to purchase a
t-shirt but how do you build a brand
essence it's it's the same kind of with
a lot of equipment nowadays it used to
be so hard for you know to get a really
good photograph well nowadays I can get
a really good photograph of my phone so
it's not about necessarily the equipment
nowadays it's about the content and I
think that's really what made us
successful back in the day was hiring
the right photographers artists
videographers you know all that stuff to
produce the right content for all of our
marketing especially for DC it was some
of the first guys to take high quality
like black and white shots of of
athletes and not just black and white of
course but it seems like we're is that
accurate that you mean you guys were at
least that that's what I had read that
you you were some of the first people to
really place an emphasis on that yeah I
mean there was all sorts of different
campaigns that we did you know various
different things in black and white but
I for us a lot of it was connecting with
the consumer in a different way and in a
way that they wanted information and
when I say that I mean even when you
watch a simple video you can capture
something on an iPhone that as long as
you capture the right essence of
something that connects that's way more
important
hiring a guy that can hold a red camera
that may make it prettier but it just
costs you 10 grand instead of pulling
out something out of your pocket you
know so for me it's always about the
storytelling it's always about you know
connecting the content with what the
consumer wants to see and and I think
we're kind of lucky I'm on my side that
they create the guys behind me enjoy we
all enjoy kind of the same stuff so we
want to produce the content that we want
to watch if that makes sense in it and I
think that that's why you see our stuff
so passionately done because we
genuinely love this stuff but back to
that storytelling thing you know I it
was funny when we started just a random
example that pops into my head we
started making ads and doing a lot of
marketing with motocross guys back in
the late 90s with DC you know we
sponsored Jeff Emig and Ryan Hughes and
and Ricky Carmichael and when we went
into the magazines we looked at
everything and the the motocross
photographers shot really tight you know
because the dirtbike sponsors wanted
them they wanted to show their logos on
the bike you know and the bike
manufacturers they wanted the consumer
to see their bike up close so you just
have all these photos of like a guy in
the air and no reference to the ground
and that sort of thing well we'd kind of
did the opposite we we hired skateboard
photographers to go shoot these dirt
bike guys and they would shoot long
lines and really show how big these guys
were jumping and then we'd we'd buy a
spread add you know and run it in
black-and-white and ricky be way up in
the sky you know and you'd see the real
distance hundred feet that he's jumping
and it it would look dramatically
different than everything else in the
magazine but that's how we stood out and
the consumers of it you know because
they're like hey you're showing the
sport that we love in a more dramatic
and beautiful way and so we really had a
huge success from those campaigns like
in motocross because we were just
standing out and doing it different but
once again delivering to the consumer
what they wanted to see
in doing in the fun and unique way so
you know and we kind of carried that
everywhere including like random example
the director of photography that I use
for like Jim Connaughton he's a
snowboarder he doesn't know anything
about cars like he's but he has a
certain eyes name's Pierre Rick Berg
I've known him but I don't know almost
20 years he used to have a company
called robot food and they made
snowboard films and we hired him to make
two films Mountain lab mount lab 1.5
about our research and development
facility that was my home here in Park
City but they were some of the most fun
and creative movies because Pierre has
such an eye for not only filming and
making things look fun but then editing
it together with the right music and the
right story in the right feel so it's
guys like him that help make our stuff
look and feel a certain way and you know
and that's what continues to make our
stuff successful because we keep
attracting and bringing in these guys
and managing all the content in the look
the right way that we know is going to
hopefully be successful and according to
three weeks of Gymkhana ten being out
there and eleven million views so far
apparently it's still a successful so
we're pretty stoked about that so many
different directions where you go I've
so many different questions I want to
ask but let me ask you about something
you might see mundane but it's I think
it'll apply to a lot of people who are
listening in some capacity and not just
because they be involved with athletes
but I'd love to talk about the the right
way or the smart way to sponsor athletes
because you have agreements with
sponsored with athletes and I think that
you know hopefully there will be kind of
lessons people can pull from this
related to not just the specifics of
sponsoring an athlete but just thinking
about
deals and contracts ran we were chatting
about negotiation a little bit earlier
we can we'll get into that it'll say
that for another time what he did you
learn or what were some of the sort of
key takeaways that if you were let's say
one of your kids starts a company
they're gonna be sponsoring athletes
what would you are there any particular
red flags or like warnings that you'd
say well you know we tried this and the
early days it was a complete disaster
make sure you do not do this make sure
you have this kind of clause is there
anything on the macro or the micro that
comes to mind about giving your
experience which is vast how to do it
the right way sponsoring athletes um
that is a very vague and difficult
question you know it all depends on what
your ultimate goal is like is it just a
logo exposure is it trying to move a
particular product is it using the
athlete for an advertising campaign
because all those situations equal sort
of different types of contracts
different types of pay levels you know
everything so just maybe I'll try to
clarify so the reason I asked because
I've seen companies do really well
sponsoring athletes I've also seen
companies now what is sponsoring me and
in this case could be could be a
supplement it could be an apparel brand
they want someone to wear their stuff be
featured in advertisements be willing to
be quoted as a testimonial a lot of
people starting out don't even know what
the options are right they just want
someone famous or well-respected to wear
their stuff eat their stuff whatever it
might be
I've seen people also go under because
they've overpaid or not thought through
the contracts so I'm trying to wade into
this as someone who actually does not
know a lot about it but it seems to be
an integral piece of launching a lot of
different businesses yeah like I said
it's there's so many scenarios and so
many options there that it really all
depends you know if you're just trying
to get someone to wear a pair of shoes
to go do something from skateboarding to
basketball well there's a certain value
there if you're trying to put a logo on
a
that's gonna get a million views well
that's a whole different value and in
you know my case there's companies like
monster that all they want was a big
logo on the side of the car they see you
know the amount of exposure that can get
and they put a certain value on that so
it it it's it's a really difficult one I
you know and I I'm kind of amazed that
the expertise and the the understanding
of value that say someone like my agent
has because he has so many companies
come to him from Ford
you know the CB MD that that that say
hey we want this and he's able to say oh
well the basic running value of that
industry standard is this you know and
so that's where I see agents as like a
real you know real important value to
sort of this process of making sure that
the the companies getting their value
and that the athletes getting their
value out of it also so it really is
like a difficult process I actually
don't deal with any of the companies
that I work with really any more on the
negotiating side like my agent does all
of it because I don't understand what
you know Nike is paying a similar person
as me somewhere else he would understand
that and understand the value and then
how they're using them and like I that's
something that's it's it's a it's a
crazy world out there and but that that
is marketing and advertising though and
and there are very particular values
that people pay and certain athletes are
you know quite different and and even
even as you've changed countries like my
agent represents a basketball player
that actually does a lot of marketing in
China you know and there's a whole
different set of values as to how he
does that and how much time that takes
and what you know what that value and
commitment is and yeah so the question
you're asking is it's not as simple no
it's not so you asked me how much that
logo is worth
my car sitting over there I could give
you a rough idea but you know what what
you know a skateboard company pays to
put a logo on someone's t-shirt nowadays
it really is something that is quite you
know a difficult answer to answer got an
agent yeah this this particular which is
which is why I bring it up because
there's a lot of information out there
but it can be somewhat opaque and
confusing for instance if you want to
figure out what books are selling for
there's a site called publishers
marketplace and you could buy
subscription and you can see the rough
range of advances that are being paid
for different books so it's a great
source of information even though most
people aren't familiar with it or IMDB
Pro although that's not necessarily
going to get into all the dollar figures
but it gives you a level of granularity
right the the agent piece is tricky
because I mean I have agents but it's
for someone who's just getting on their
feet trying to learn they may not have
access to an agent but I suppose they
might have access to a lawyer if they're
not hiring them for a specific contract
just to walk them through like the
difficulty specific deal templates right
because I know that when I've done deals
you may you don't get what you deserve
you get what you negotiate which is why
it's so helpful to have an agent do it
on your behalf but you might that
sponsor might want category exclusivity
right you may certainly not want
category exclusivity and then you have
duration right you might have if they
want social support you're gonna want it
to be really well-defined and capped
they might not want it to be
well-defined because then it allows them
to ask for more so it's it's one of
those kind of black boxes do you is your
agent from one of the the big sort of
three-letter acronym like WMA CA one of
those guys or UTA yes wmg yeah it's
interesting to me precisely because it
is so difficult right if you're if
you're just getting started to try to
figure it out yeah but I would say if
you're a very small startup without much
budget and you're you don't really know
where you're going that could be very
difficult but if you are a bigger
company you know that has money that can
understands the business and what
they're trying to do
it makes a lot more sense you know an
agency like wmg that represents me they
also help companies with marketing with
actually making videos commercials
social media posts all that stuff so
they're actually a full-service agency
because back in the day you would have
your ad agency over here on the left
you'd have your age it's over here on
the right and nowadays that stuff's
getting much more all-in-one yeah
because like an agency like wmg and my
agent Steve somebody can call and say
this is what we want to accomplish these
are the people we want to connect with
and not only can the agent determine
what athlete is right for what they're
trying to achieve they can then help
them write the campaign and actually get
the connections directly with those
consumers not only with the company's
social media but with the athletes
social media because we're able to
target things through Facebook and
Instagram and you know and obviously
make the right messaging with the videos
photos or whatever to to really reach
what someone's trying to market towards
so that's why I say it's a very
difficult question and it is genuinely
different when you talk about a really
small company someone with varying
experience and very little money
compared to like you know if a bigger
company says hey we want to grow into
this category how can we do that how can
we hire the right athlete that's where
an agency like wmg can really help
maximize that in a much bigger way
nowadays yeah and and most all of them
are doing that a lot a lot of these
agencies have really realized hey we
need to be full service like this is a
big world now and social media has made
things much more dynamic than in the
past
you know because when I started DC it
was like oh we need to make one
skateboard at a month we need one
message [ __ ] nowadays you need eight
mini messages just for Instagram you
know and so the world has gotten so much
more direct so much more I would say
complicated and complicated in a way
that your brand
and your voice needs to be very thought
through very well put together and done
multiple times a day which is much more
difficult than when I started
yeah for sure and just to put a button
in the in in this kind of topic I would
just say for folks also if you can't get
an agent don't want to get an agent
because you don't necessarily want to
get married and then figure out the
specifics for something like this with
say endorsement contracts and so on you
can find entertainment attorneys and
they'll be more than happy to take your
money or to give you a 101 education it
will not be cheap but it'll it'll cost
you a few thousand dollars you can a
pretty good baseline and ask for a
template agreement if you just pay them
for a template agreement given whatever
your basic parameters are you can
actually learn a lot from that now you
are 50/50 one at the moment fifty one
fifty one you are still very physically
active what does your training look like
on a weekly basis or on a daily basis
what is that what does that look like ah
I hate the gym but I realize it's a tool
that I have to use so I'm in the gym
three or four times a week doing stuff
like I did an hour of kickboxing today
was a very good trainer I also have a
regular physical strength trainer I've
had some tears in my left shoulder so
I'm actually using a very good trainer
right now that specializes in shoulder
rehabilitation so he's actually been
able to take me from not being able to
do a push-up for two years to actually
functioning really quite normally so I
spend probably about four hours a week
in the gym doing everything from you
know high output intervals to you know
basic weight training and on top of that
I try and get out and do as much sort of
physical outside activity as I possibly
can from snowboarding with my kids to
downhill mountain biking I hike a lot
with my dogs in the winter I basically
live right next to the park
city mountain so I hike up into the
mountains and snowboard back down I just
loved the cardio of it and it's a great
way to get my dogs out and get them
exercise and I take my snowboard because
it's extra weight on me and then instead
of walking back down in the snow which
is just not fun at all me and there's no
physical benefit the walking down I can
stumble back down and be at my house in
five minutes so it's it's stuff like
that that I really enjoy getting
outdoors and doing but the one thing
that I really enjoy about sort of the
outdoor stuff is like keeping me sharp
mentally like downhill mountain biking
the the quickness and reaction that you
need on that stuff and the the potential
risk to injury and/or death really keeps
you sharp so I enjoy getting out and
doing that stuff as much as possible but
at the end of day like for what I need
the reaction stuff like kickboxing
really being physical in that sort of
way was what I think helps benefit me
the most when I get in the race car and
go race so I really enjoy you know those
things that really keep me mentally
sharp and hopefully keep me sort of
young you thought you've definitely had
no no shortage of injuries or enemy that
if your fair share was is there anything
that you've stopped doing where certain
types of exercise or certain types of
driving where you've you've taken it off
the table for yourself as you've as
you've gotten older um two things I
don't write dirt bikes anymore it's so
easy to get hurt on a dirt bike I loved
her bike riding and it's just
unfortunately you know it's called hurt
bike for a reason or the other thing is
with age comes a cage but you know I
absolutely love it but you know it's the
risk you know I used to ride a lot of
tracks I loved track riding and big
jumps that sort of thing but I've also
been injured many times from it you know
so I've quit doing that just because the
risk you know if I can't show up to one
of the events that I'm paid to go race
or go do demos at or what
because I hurt myself on the dirt bike
well that's just dumb so I don't do that
anymore
and the other thing is uh for because of
the physical side of it is I used to do
you know ice to go out and run with my
dogs they used to play racquetball but
my ankle my right ankle has gotten so
damaged from skateboarding and
snowboarding over the years there's a
lot of calcium buildup they actually
call arthritis but it just sounds like a
very old person term to me but it's
actually from just all the impacts of
skateboarding and snowboarding and then
actually rolling my ankle from
skateboarding that there's just a bunch
of calcium built up around the joint
itself so I went to a doctor in San
Diego
you know that's worked on a bunch of
different skateboarders and snowboarders
he's very good doctor and he's like ah I
could fix that for you it'd be six
months of pain and rehabilitation it's
like do you make money right playing
racquetball and I'm like nope he's like
like just quit doing that yeah so I had
to quit playing racquetball and I like
racquetball but I liked the mental and
physical challenge of it because you're
having to predict where the ball is
going having to turn rotate move react
like I really love that training to make
me quick to be in the car and I just I
just had to give it up have you had to
modify it how you do your kickboxing
training because of the ankle or other
injuries uh no because the you know just
doing pad work and a little bit of
sparring it isn't that bad even I was I
did a bunch of kicks this morning and
hurts the top of my foot because I
didn't place my foot where I should have
on the pad that's my own mistake but
other than that it doesn't really bother
me whatsoever and even uh because I do
need some wrist strength and forearm
strength I actually work with a lighter
glove like a and like it it's not a real
MMA glove it
it has padded fingers and all that but
it's a very it's a much lighter glove
and I don't actually wrap my wrists so
it actually keeps my wrists and my
forearms and actually very strong so I
don't have it I've broken both
before but my research boxing doctor
bike-to-bike and snowboarding but they
seem very strong now and just this
process of not rapping and doing this
pad work keeps them even stronger we're
gonna wrap up in just a little bit but
so to speak but I wanted to ask you and
I asked a lot of my guests this because
it's there there are people who listen
to these podcasts or see your
accomplishments and feel very
intimidated and think that it's always
been home runs one after the other you
to humanize things a bit is could you
talk about maybe a tough time that
you've experienced or a time of
self-doubt whether it's with DC or
otherwise just a specific situation or a
period of time that you could tell us
about I would say you know one one part
of time with DC growing was you know
when you reach a certain level and
things start to flatten out you know and
there was a point in time what DC that
you know the guy running the business
side of the company was doing things
what we eventually found out wasn't
exactly the most approved way by the IRS
and and then he wasn't treating the IRS
officials very well and at the same time
we're struggling as a company and you
know it really was a hard lesson for us
to learn of of what it really takes to
run a company through the tough times
and those are the times that you learned
the most from the easy times when things
are all up and up and you can't do
anything wrong you actually don't learn
that much from those times it's when you
have your failures that certain products
just aren't working or maybe that the
market you're in turns left and you're
still going right in our or the business
practices that you have going on behind
the scenes you think are you know all on
the up-and-up maybe people aren't doing
things exactly what to the directives
that you think they are and those are
the times that you make the adjustments
that you you really dig down and
learn what you need to learn to direct
the company the way that you need to and
those times are some of the most
uncomfortable that I've ever had sitting
and sitting in a room full of you know
attorneys and suits and sit there in a
pair of tea you know a pair of you know
DC skate shoes and a t-shirt you know
and having to make these decisions that
are way to me what would have been way
beyond my experience level but I dug
down in we researched we read we worked
hard to find the the knowledge that we
needed to succeed and those are the
times that we learned ourselves the most
from and I know I'm sorry that those
aren't very specific but you know for a
company like they what we had you know
there were plenty of times that we hired
athletes and they didn't work out or we
made a particular shoe and like the
consumer just didn't want that you know
but at those times too it's you're not
relying on one you have 50 products one
may fail okay we still these others are
succeeding or we have 15 athletes we
hire neuen
oh he didn't work out damn it we tried
you really like this guy but he just
didn't perform we got to move on you
know and and and that's just the way it
is but you know those are little lessons
the bigger lessons really are the the
larger business things that like for me
as as a marketing guy you know we really
did try to hire much smarter people than
us in those areas but when it came down
to it we still had to make the decisions
we still had to say no this is the right
way to go we gotta let this guy go he he
doesn't get what we're trying to do or
there's other people that just didn't
have the same integrity that we did and
you know weren't acting in the same
light that we were and didn't represent
us the right way okay you got to go to
you know and those are hard decisions
and when I mean [ __ ] I made a lot of
those decisions when I was in my late
twenties and early thirties you know
it's when I still drank a lot just a
different mentality now than I have
today but it was a great learning
experience and I came out better at the
their end and so you no longer you don't
no longer drink I still drink just that
same level quite have the same how would
you say stamina to wake up the next
morning and and to do things at the same
level of the day it just affects me more
than others so unless some couple of
light questions favorite drink so what
is your favorite drink Wow
like favorite alcoholic drink favorite
alcoholic drink my favorite alcoholic
drink I have two of them right now in
the summer it's called a long drink it's
the official drink of Finland okay it's
it's just something that they made for
when they held the Olympics in Finland a
long time ago they like we need an
official drink it's like gin and
grapefruit juice and it comes in a can
it's amazing it's amazing summer drink
but then year round I actually really
like good sipping tequila like Class A
Azul something like that just over some
ice just amazing do you have a default
breakfast these days verrat a favorite
breakfast I I find that I actually work
the best and work out the best in the
morning but I hate spending the time to
make breakfast and/or digest that
breakfast
I want caffeine in me as fast as
possible and I want to be able to work
as much as possible in warning and
workout so I found that just drinking
coffee and eating a light breakfast
worked really well but nowadays I drink
basically like a bulletproof coffee like
coffee with butter and MCT oil in it but
then with on it makes a very good mix
that goes into it with flaxseed chia
seed that sort of thing Hamilton yeah
called a vitality mix and so I drink
that every morning and that last me till
11 or 12 o'clock every day and I get a
great workout in I get a lot of work
done and that that to me is one of those
little life hacks that you know that
people have come up with the it's not
it's kind of an unusual thing but man if
you can get on it really works
do you have any wind down or pre bed
rituals anything you
due to start shutting down before you go
to go to sleep oh wow that's a tough one
um try not to look at social media for
about half hour before you know it as I
get older the messed up thing about
getting older is it seems like sleep
gets harder just really silly my mom's
like 85 and it's really hard for her to
sleep so I I feel like the actual best
sleep ritual is actually working out
really hard during the day instead of
form or another like your body actually
physically feeling tired going to sleep
and then getting a good recovery by a
very good deep sleep is really key to me
but as far as really winding down I mean
I you know I have three semi young kids
my oldest is 12 so you know we spend
every night doing something with the
kids and then putting them to bed and
then my wife and I hang out doing
whatever drink glass of wine hopefully
not too late and and have a mellow
evening go to bed so it's not everything
specific besides trying not to look at
electronics too late at night and get
the exercise that's that's a huge huge
component yeah it amazes me how many
people don't realize that if you're
going to be a successful functioning
human that you've got to eat well you've
got to take care of yourself you've got
to be in good physical condition like it
your mental abilities to actually
coincide with your physical abilities
yeah and if you put crap into yourself
you're gonna get a crap output yeah you
know and so I'm a firm believer and you
know good exercise you know there's a
you got to take care yourself really
well physically to really expect a high
output mentally yeah kind of protect the
asset last one or two questions here if
you could put a message or a quote or a
word non-commercial on this is a
metaphorical question on a billboard
that millions or billions of people
would see is there anything that comes
to mind any type of message question
don't be an [ __ ]
that's acceptable that's perfectly
acceptable well the funny thing is I say
that because I feel like like social
media is just like in the Internet's
made it so that you're not talking to
people anymore it's so easy to be rude
you know and that's one thing I really
impart you know and my kids are like you
got to look at people in their face and
make a statement
you know you greet someone you look them
in the eye you know you cheers them you
don't look away when your glasses hit in
the other glass you look them in the eye
you know and I and I just feel like like
the human nature of of us as beings on
this earth we got to treat everybody in
a good and fair way and that if we all
did that the planet would be a lot
better but you know so that's that's a
basic very basic thing but on top of
that though I think we're here or you
know we're not here for a long time but
let's have a good time let's let's be
innovative let's be creative let's have
fun you know there's a lot of [ __ ] out
there in the world that we got to deal
with but let's let's do things in a
better way let's do things in a fun and
creative way why not why I'd be stuck
with the mundane and and beset with the
[ __ ] like I want to be creative I
want to be fun I want to want to do
things the best way I possibly can and I
want to be proud of whatever I do
there's everything in life if it comes
to like you know from the simplest thing
to the biggest thing I want to be proud
of what it is and and stake my claims
that's mine and that's how I do it
you're here get up but don't be an
[ __ ]
I think it gets us it gets us checks a
lot of boxes
well can I really appreciate you taking
time today this was really fun it was
also fun to be in your backyard and
playing in the snow for a few days
before getting a chance to to sit down
together is there anything in particular
you'd like people to check out certainly
they can say hello
Instagram at K block 43 also K block 43
on Twitter Facebook ken block racing
Hoonigan racing calm
are there any particular things that
you're creating working on or have
created that you'd like people to take a
look at well Jim can attend the tenth
installment of this video series just
came out recently it's on YouTube and
the Gymkhana files which is the
documentary series that Amazon had us
create around what I do with making
these Jim Khanna videos and racing and
all that stuff that's on Amazon Prime
right now both of them are very good
it's weird that we've made a documentary
about me you know what I do but I think
it's very cool and we you know the
documentary genre out there has become
very popular it's something I really
enjoy so for us to make one was really
cool and fun and it's it's a bit
different than what what else you see
out there because were we're showing
people what we do how we do it to make
these viral videos that have become a
big part of everybody's life nowadays
and we've really pulled back the curtain
to show what it takes to do this stuff
and that was a lot of fun to do but
different than a lot of other you know
documentary series at the end you
actually get a prize you actually get to
see the end result of what we did you
know unlike the Clinton affair
documentary you know what the end result
is it's it's a cool way that they
actually told that documentary and I
really enjoyed it
but at the end yeah he gets impeached
but then he doesn't get impeached he did
a bunch of bad stuff we all know about
it it was a cool story but our
documentary series actually was a cool
twist on all that that at the end you
actually get to see what we spent two
years making you know which i think was
a really cool and innovative on amazon's
part to hire us to do all this and it
was fun for us to take you know this
experience of making these viral videos
and then tell that whole story and show
it how it all comes to life so yeah if
whoever's you know listening to this go
check out you know Jim Connaughton and
the Gymkhana files and all that's
produced by our small company called
hoonigan that you can find easily online
and if you're into cars they make all
sorts of crazy
in different content that covers you
know various car builds around the world
and doing funny stuff with cars and and
doing very serious things with cars so
it's it's a great and fun brand that we
have and it's been grown a lot because
we've been able to do very creative and
fun projects well we could talk I'm sure
we could talk for many more hours we
didn't get a chance to talk about hamona
barek oh yeah or Nobu or the UFC gym in
Vegas but we can do that another time
folks I will also link to everything
we've talked about including the videos
that can just mentioned in the show
notes as per usual so you can find all
those links at tim dot blog forward
slash podcast just search Ken's name and
it will pop right up ken thanks again
for taking the time yeah thank you I
really enjoyed actually talking about
this stuff and especially in a format
where hopefully people will listen and
actually take some of the lessons and
knowledge that I have and hopefully
apply it to their own experiences and
hopefully better themselves yeah well
I've been I've been very impressed over
the years watching your longevity and
also how you've sort of folded one
project into the next and how the
relationships and skills you've built
from one thing if transferred then into
other projects in seemingly distinct
worlds it's been it's been really fun
and instructive just to watch from afar
so it's nice to actually be sitting in
here having a conversation well thank
you very much for having me alright guys
until next time thanks for listening hey
guys this is Tim again just a few more
things before you take off number one
this is five bullet Friday do you want
to get a short email from me would you
enjoy getting a short email from me
every Friday and that provides a little
morsel of fun for the weekend
and five bullet Friday is a very short
email where I share the coolest things
I've found or that I've been pondering
over the week that could include
favorite new albums that I've discovered
it could include gizmos and gadgets and
all sorts of weird [ __ ] that I've
somehow dug up in the the world of the
esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek comm all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you'll get the very next one and if
you sign up I hope you enjoyed this
episode of the Tim Ferriss shows brought
to you by athletic greens I get us all
the time if I could only take one
supplement what would it be
the answer is inevitably athletic greens
I view it as and a lot of you now view
it as all in one nutritional insurance I
recommended it way back in 2010 in the
4-hour body and I did not get behaved to
do so I've been using it since before
that they use it in a lot of different
ways I travel with it to avoid getting
sick or to help mitigate the likelihood
of getting sick I take it in the morning
to ensure optimal performance and
overall it covers my bases if I can't
get what I need from whole food meals
throughout the rest of the day and if
you want to give athletic greens a try
they're offering a free 20 count travel
pack for first-time users I nearly
always travel with at least three or
four of these one dose bags in other
words if you buy athletic greens as a
first-time buyer you now get for a
limited time and extra $79 in free
product so check out the details at
athletic greens com forward slash Tim
again that's athletic greens com forward
slash Tim for your free travel pack with
any purchase this episode is brought to
you by LinkedIn marketing solutions the
go-to tool for b2b marketers and
advertisers who want to drive brand
awareness generate leads or build
long-term relationships that result in
real business impact could be all of the
above I've had Reid Hoffman cofounders
LinkedIn on this podcast a number of
times
often called the Oracle of Silicon
Valley for many different reasons
and he among other people and friends of
mine have made me more and more
interested in LinkedIn as a platform as
an ecosystem in the last few years and
it's it's very nuanced it's very subtle
but can be used in some very powerful
ways with a community of more than five
hundred and seventy five million
professionals LinkedIn is gigantic but
it can be hyper specific you have access
to a very diverse group of people all
searching for things they need to grow
professionally that is explicitly the
purpose of LinkedIn and four out of five
users on LinkedIn are decision makers at
their companies so you can build
relationships that really matter that
can drive your business objectives
forward but it can also have a high LTV
lifetime of the value LinkedIn has the
marketing tools to help you target your
customers with precision right down to
among other things their job title
company name industry etc this is
important because better targeting
equals a message that your customers
actually care about and it also means
your advertising is more effective and
cost effective so why spray-and-pray
with your marketing dollars when you can
be surgical it just makes sense to
redeem a free $100 LinkedIn ad credit
and launch your first campaign go to
linkedin.com /tf s that stands for Tim
Ferriss show so that is linkedin.com /t
FS check it out that's where you can go
to get your free $100 ad credit LinkedIn
comm board slash TFS terms and
conditions apply
[Applause]
you
you
you